Congratulations, you have completed unit 5.
You have a search engine that can respond to queries quickly,
no matter how large the index gets.
This problem of analyzing the cost of algorithms
and designing data structures that are more efficient,
is one of the core ideas in all of computer science.
It's something we go into a lot more depth on in later courses
that I hope you will take after finishing CS101,
including the Algorithms and Theory of Computation course.
The main thing we have left to do for our search engine,
is to find a way to get the best page for a given query, instead of all pages.
This is the main thing that made Google so successful -
figuring out a better way to identify the pages
searchers really care about.
Thats what we are going to look at in unit 6.
Hope to see you back soon!